David Boder: [In English] Italy, September the second, 1946, in Tradate—between Milano and Como, a displaced persons’ community given to self government of a number of Kibbuzim. That means small, formed Zionistic groups, which intend to enter Palestine by legal or illegal means, hm, whichever possible. Hm, the interviewee is Miss Esther Krüger, 20 years old
David Boder: [In German] Zu welchem Kibbuz gehören Sie?
David Boder: [In English] Belonging to the Kibbuz Nochum.
David Boder: [In German] Also Fräulein Krüger, sagen Sie mir, wie heißen Sie und wie alt sind Sie und von wo sind Sie?
Esther Krueger: Ich bin alt zwanzig (20) Jahre, von Kielce und im Kibbuz Nochum.
David Boder: Ja, Sie sind von Kielce.
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: Nun erzählen Sie uns, was hat Ihnen passiert, wenn Sie...wenn der Krieg hat angefangen.
Esther Krueger: Also [unverständlich]
David Boder: Also was Sie sich denken. Sie brauchen nicht zu geben...den exakten Tag oder was. Wo seid Ihr gewesen in Kielce - es ist gewesen?
Esther Krueger: Meinen Sie in welchem Lager?
David Boder: Nein, nein, nein. Wo hast Du gewohnt, daheim?
Esther Krueger: Ich? In Kielce.
David Boder: Hm, Ihr habt gewohnt in...?
Esther Krueger: Kielce.
David Boder: In Kielce, mit wem denn?
Esther Krueger: Mit der ganzen Familie.
David Boder: Ja und wie viele?
Esther Krueger: Die Eltern und Schwestern, Brüder.
David Boder: Wie viele Schwestern und wie viele Brüder?
Esther Krueger: Ich habe gehabt drei (3) Schwestern und drei (3) Brüder.
David Boder: Drei (3) Brüder.
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: Seien Sie gewesen älter oder jünger?
Esther Krueger: Ein Bruder war älter und...
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: . . . und Einer jünger.
David Boder: Also ein Bruder, Ein Älterer und...
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: . . . und drei (3) Schwestern, jüngerer?
Esther Krueger: Drei Schwester jüngerer und zwei Brüder...
David Boder: Zwei Brüder.
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: So sind sie gewesen im Ganzen acht (8)...sieben (7) Kinder.
David Boder: Und mit Ihren Eltern waren...
Esther Krueger: Auch.
David Boder: . . . waren es neun (9) Menschen in der Familie?
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter. Ja. Nun und was war die Beschäftigung von Ihrem Vater?
Esther Krueger: Mein Vater hat gearbeitet mit...hm, Stoffen.
David Boder: Mit Stoffen.
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: Hatte er ein Geschäft?
Esther Krueger: Ja. Und die Mutter auch.
David Boder: Die Mutter war auch mit in dem Geschäft?
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: Ja, nun, haben sie gut verdient?
Esther Krueger: Ja, hm, sie haben gut verdient,...wir haben ein gutes Leben.
David Boder: Ein gutes Leben. Was für eine Bildung habt ihr bekommen?
Esther Krueger: Ich bin gegangen in die Schule.
David Boder: Was für eine Schule?
Esther Krueger: Volksschule, ich war noch jung.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Sechzehn Jahre, da habe ich die Volksschule sieben (7) Jahre...
David Boder: Sieben Klassen von...
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: . . . Volksschule.
Esther Krueger: Und nachher ins Lager gehen.
David Boder: Also, ein Moment, nicht so schnell. Also, wenn der Krieg hat angefangen seid ihr gewesen in Kielce.
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: Also wer sind hereingekommen? Sind die Deutschen herein gekommen nach Kielce?
Esther Krueger: Die Deutschen.
David Boder: Also erzählen Sie mir, was hat passiert, wenn die Deutschen sind rein gekommen nach Kielce? Was ist passiert zu Euch? Nun, sprechen Sie.
Esther Krueger: Wie die Deutschen gekommen sind nach Kielce haben sie verhaftet für Zwangsarbeit.
David Boder: Also sagen Sie mir, wie bald, gleich oder in ein paar Tagen oder?
Esther Krueger: Gleich.
David Boder: . . . oder ein paar Tage später, oder wie ist es gewesen?
Esther Krueger: Wann?
David Boder: Nicht ganz genau...
Esther Krueger: Es war im zwei und vierzigsten (42.) Jahr.
David Boder: Im zwei und vierzigste (42.) Jahr.
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: Wie hat man das gemacht für Zwangsarbeit? Wie...
Esther Krueger: Man hat es gebraucht für die Munitionsfabrik, nach Skarzysko.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Und man hat geschnappt für Zwangsarbeit...für Munitionsfabrik.
David Boder: Nun, wie hat man das...? Was hat Euch passiert?
Esther Krueger: Damals...
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Damals hat man gegründet eine jüdisches Kommune.
David Boder: Gemeinde, ja.
Esther Krueger: Ja, ein Jüdisches. Und haben [unverständlich] zur Arbeit.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Hat man mich auch genommen zur Arbeit. Aber ich habe öfter mal entflohen, weil ich wollte zusammen sein mit meinen Eltern.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Und so hat man mich genommen zwangs, ja, die Polizei, die Jüdische.
David Boder: Von der jüdischen Polizei.
Esther Krueger: Polizei.
David Boder: Also, wenn Sie waren bei der Zwangsarbeit—haben Sie gearbeitet und sind dann jeden Abend nach Hause?
Esther Krueger: Ja, ich bin gefahren zur Arbeit um sieben (7) Uhr und gekommen nach Hause um fünf (5) Uhr.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Für eine gewisse Zeit, vielleicht zwei (2) Monate habe ich so gearbeitet.
Esther Krueger: Und nachher hat man gesagt, es kommt eine Aussiedlung.
David Boder: Aha, nun, nachher, also weiter. Wie ist die Aussiedlung durch gegangen. Erzählen Sie alles mit die Kleinigkeiten, nun?
Esther Krueger: Ich bin aufgestanden in der Früh und habe gesehen meine Mutti. Nachher hab ich nicht gewollt in die Arbeit gehen und meine Mutti hat sehr geweint und gesagt, ich gehe nicht in die Arbeit , dann werd ich gehalten in den Barracken.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Also ich musste gehen in die Arbeit.
David Boder: Nun warten Sie. Wie? In welchen Baracken? Ist Ihre Mutter schon gewesen in den Baracken?
Esther Krueger: Nein, meine Mutti ist gewesen zu Hause.
David Boder: Ja. Hat sie...(beiden sprechen)
Esther Krueger: Aber...
David Boder: . . . hat sie gewusst, dass sie kommen zur Aussiedlung?
Esther Krueger: Wir haben nicht gewusst, nicht genau gewusst.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Leute haben so darüber gesprochen. Heute wird Aussiedlung sein. Und wenn Aussiedlung wird sein, dann wird man den Block behalten in den Baracken.
David Boder: Aha.
Esther Krueger: Da habe ich selber bekommen Angst gehen zur Arbeit.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Aber meine Mutti hat gesagt: ‚Hab keine Angst. Heute werden sie uns nicht in den Baracken erreichen.’ Und ich bin gegangen zu der Arbeit.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Und ich bin den ganzen Tag bei der Arbeit und man hat uns gehalten.
David Boder: Wen?
Esther Krueger: Uns—alle Mädchen.
David Boder: Oh, alle Mädchen, die bei der...
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: .. Arbeit waren.
Esther Krueger: Bei der Arbeit.
David Boder: Oh, man hat sie gehalten bei der Arbeit, nun?
Esther Krueger: Behalten in den Baracken, nicht mehr gelassen nach Hause.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Weil wir sind jeden Tag gekommen um 5 Uhr nach Hause.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Aber diese Tage hat man nach Hause nicht mehr gelassen.
David Boder: Wo ist die Baracke gewesen? Bei der Fabrik?
Esther Krueger: Die Baracke ist gewesen in .. bei der Fabrik.
David Boder: Aha
Esther Krueger: In Skarzysko.
David Boder: Aha. Nun?
Esther Krueger: Und nachher habe ich gesehen das Ärgste. Und ich habe mir vorgestellt, dass ich bleibe selbst ohne meine Eltern.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Ich habe viel geweint. Ich habe so geweint, ich habe da bekommen von einem...SS Mann eine bekommen, ich konnte nicht gesehen die Hände vor meinen Augen.
David Boder: Was hast Du bekommen? Eine Ohrfeige?
Esther Krueger: Ich hab so eine...
David Boder: Er hat Dich geschlagen ins Gesicht.
Esther Krueger: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Esther Krueger: Damals [unverständlich] und habe nicht beherrscht die Gewalt
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Es war das Ärgste, das mir passiert im Leben.
David Boder: Was?
Esther Krueger: Zu bleiben ohne Eltern, ohne Schwestern und Brüdern sein.
David Boder: Nun?
Esther Krueger: Aber das hat gar nichts gemacht; ich habe müssen bleiben in den Baracken. Und meine Eltern sind noch geblieben zu Hause—vielleicht vier (4) Wochen.
David Boder: Ja und wo sind Sie geblieben? In den Baracken diese 4 Wochen?
Esther Krueger: Und ich bin geblieben in die Baracken und nachher habe ich bekommen von daheim Schriften und ich habe auch geschrieben—durch Polnische.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Esther Krueger: Und meine Mutti hat geschrieben zu mir, die Aussiedlung ist geblieben und erst in drei (3) Monaten. Aber es ist nicht gewesen wahr. Meine Mutti hat das geschrieben, dass ich mir nicht so viele, hm, hm,...
David Boder: Sorgen?
Esther Krueger: Sorgen machen sollte.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Und nachher...
David Boder: Hat Ihre Mutter geschrieben durch die Post?
Esther Krueger: Die Post, ja, durch die Polnischen.
David Boder: Ja, also man hat nicht dürfen Briefe bekommen
Esther Krueger: Wie bitte?
David Boder: Man hat nicht erlaubt, dass Sie bekommen Briefe.
Esther Krueger: Nicht erlaubt, nein.
David Boder: Nein.
Esther Krueger: Es war nicht erlaubt.
David Boder: Aber sie wurden geschickt durch die Geheimen, polnische Post.
Esther Krueger: Ja, sie haben die Briefe gebracht ins Lager.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Esther Krueger: Und nachher ist gewesen.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Da habe ich auch geschrieben nach Hause einen Tag vorher.
Esther Krueger: Und ich habe bekommen jeden zweiten (2.) Tag einen Brief. Die Polnischen sind gekommen am nächsten Tag und haben gesagt, sie haben keinen Brief mehr bekommen, es waren alle schon ausgesiedelt.
David Boder: An Yom Kippur?
Esther Krueger: An Yom Kippur, am selben Tag.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Ganz früh um drei (3) Uhr Nacht hat man sie geweckt.
Esther Krueger: Und die Mutti hat müssen aufstehen mit die kleinen Kinder, nehmen alles und raus aus dem Haus.
David Boder: Also sind sie noch gewesen in der Synagoge an Yom Kippur am Abend. Sind die Leute noch zu Kol Nidrei gegangen?
Esther Krueger: Ja, sie sind noch gegangen in der Nacht und sind dann nach Hause. Und haben gar nichts gewusst.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Um 3 Uhr sind sie dann ausgesiedelt.
David Boder: Ja. Wer waren sie...und wie alt sind die kleinen Kinder gewesen?
Esther Krueger: Die Jüngste, meine Schwester, war vier (4) Jahre alt.
David Boder: Und Ihr Vater ist auch genommen worden?
Esther Krueger: Mein Vater ist auch gewesen im Lager. Aber im zweiten (2.) dort. Ich bin gewesen in Baracke B und mein Vater ist gewesen in Baracke A.
David Boder: Ah, das ist...schon...schon von früher?
Esther Krueger: Früher. Aber ich habe nichts gewusst von meinem Vater. Man hat mir gesagt, mein Vater ist nach Hause gefahren deshalb, weil er hat bekommen schwache Augen. Habe mich so gefreut, dass mein Vater...(beide sprechen)
David Boder: We hat bekommen schwache Augen?
Esther Krueger: . . . zusammen, ja...
David Boder: Und?
Esther Krueger: . . . mit meiner Mutti ist.
David Boder: Ja. War das so?
Esther Krueger: Nein. Ich habe geschrieben nach Hause, aber meine Mutti hat gar nicht geantwortet. Und nachher ein Jahr später hat man mir gesagt, mein Vater ist gestorben bevor die Aussiedlung von Skarzysko ist getan.
David Boder: Hm. Also man hat Deinen Vater auch genommen in die Baracken?
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Ja, mein Vater war auch mit in der Baracke, aber mein Vater hat gearbeitet an Holz.
David Boder: Wie alt ist er gewesen?
Esther Krueger: Mein Vater war ein und vierzig (41) Jahre.
David Boder: Ein und vierzig (41) Jahre?
Esther Krueger: Ein und vierzig (41) Jahre.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Mein Vater hat gearbeitet bei Holz in Karlstadt und ein großer Baum ist gefallen auf seine Füss und da hat er...
David Boder: Ein Großer was? Grosse Bäume, ja.
Esther Krueger: . . . ist gefallen auf seine Füße und mein Vater hat das Bein gebrochen.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Dann ist der Vater ins Spital gekommen und gestorben.
David Boder: Hm, nun. Also was hat passiert in dieser Nacht, wo (vielleicht Shemed - unverständlich) war. Was hat man Euch erzählt?
Esther Krueger: Man hat mir erzählt so. Wenn meine Mutti und meine Brüder sind gegangen nach Kol Nidrei und sind gekommen nach Hause, haben sie gar nichts gewusst. Sie sind dann schlafen gegangen wie an jedem anderen Tage.
David Boder: Ist dort gewesen ein Ghetto?
Esther Krueger: Es soll ein Kibbuzim sein..
David Boder: Ja, es ist gewesen—ein Ghetto.
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: In Kielce?
David Boder: Nun.
Esther Krueger: Und nachher - um drei (3) Uhr ist gekommen die jüdische Polizei und haben geweckt. Mein Mutter hat nicht gewusst, was geschehen hat oder was da passiert, aber sie hat verstanden sie muss fertig sein. Und dann ist ein SS Mann gekommen und haben...sie haben herum gestellt um das ganze Städtchen SS Männer.
David Boder: Wer seien gewesen die SS Männer, Deutsche oder Ukrainer?
Esther Krueger: Es ware Deutsche und Ukrainer auch, aber meistens Deutsche. Sie haben sehr geschlagen die Juden. Und das Ärgste ist dann passiert, egal ob es eine Frau oder ein Mann war, man hat sie tot geschlagen. Und meine Mutti ist aufgestanden, auch die Kinder und sie haben das Haus verlassen, vielleicht so um sechs (6) Uhr. Das ist was ich gehört habe, aber ich weiß es nicht genau.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Vielleicht so um sechs (6) haben zwei sie weg geführt nach den Wagonen und sie sind mit Wagonen, die geschlossen sind gewesen, die mit Kalk aus geschmissen worden sind; kein Wasser haben sie nicht bekommen.
David Boder: Nun ja. Das haben Sie nicht selbst gesehen.
Esther Krueger: Das habe ich alles gehört.
David Boder: Ja, also das haben wir von den Anderen gehört. Nun, was hat Euch passiert?
Esther Krueger: Und ich bin geblieben im Lager. Damals habe ich noch nichts (unverständlich—beide sprechen)
David Boder: In den Baracken?
Esther Krueger: In den Baracken, ja. Ich habe damals schon nicht mehr gewusst, was wird sein mit meinem Leben, ob ich überlebe oder ob es das Ende ist von meinem Leben. Aber ich habe gearbeitet an den Maschinen. Ich habe sehr fleissig gearbeitet und hab bekommen einen guten Namen bekommen von dem deutschen Meister.
David Boder: Ein was?
Esther Krueger: Bei dem deutschen Meister einen guten Namen, ich habe gut gearbeitet.
David Boder: Einen guten Namen?
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: Bei ihm. Nun?
Esther Krueger: Und ich habe damals bei Bürstenmaschine.
David Boder: Was haben Sie da gemacht? Was hat...
Esther Krueger: Die Bürstenmaschine haben geputzt die, diese Hülsen...
David Boder: Ja, die Munitionshülsen.
Esther Krueger: Ja, die Munitionshülsen. Und nachher habe ich mehr Suppe bekommen. Das Wichtigste in dem Lager war sich halten rein, immer, ja. Immer rein, auf sich achten und achten auf die Arbeit.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Und das war bei mir alles in Ordnung. Ich habe mich sehr gut verhalten dort. Ich habe...wir haben bekommen für sieben (7) Mann ein Kilo neunzig (1.9 kg) Brot. Ich habe da mit meiner Freundin—ich habe da ein Mädchen von zu Hause als Freundin—wir konnten da verkaufen eine Portion Brot.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Und dafür Seife kaufen.
David Boder: Wofür?
Esther Krueger: Zum Waschen.
David Boder: Und was für ein Brot war das gewesen? War es gebacken jeden Tag?
Esther Krueger: Das ist gewesen so: einige Tage war es frisch, aber dann war es auch schon verschimmelt auch.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Altes Brot.
Esther Krueger: Es war verschieden. So wir...
David Boder: So haben Sie das Brot verkauf um Seife zu kaufen.
Esther Krueger: Ja, wir haben verkauft eine Portion Brot an zwei (2) Mann, um zu kaufen die Seife.
David Boder: Zwei Mann.
Esther Krueger: Zwei (2).
David Boder: Zwei (2) Mädchen. Ja.
Esther Krueger: Ja, zwei (2) Mädchen. Und wir haben...eine Portion Brot haben wir aufgegessen.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Jeden Tag haben wir das Brot bekommen am Abend. Und wenn wir waren sehr hungrig, haben wir das Brot gegessen. Am Abend. In der Früh haben wir müssen warten bis zwölf (12 (Uhr) zu Mittag. [unverständlich] war verschieden. Einen Tag ist es gewesen bloß Wasser. Zwei Tag später ist es schon gewesen so ein bisschen Erbsensuppe oder so mit Kartoffel, so verschieden die Suppe.
David Boder: Hat man Brot gegeben zu Mittag wieder?
Esther Krueger: Nein, zu Mittag haben wir kein Brot nicht bekommen.
David Boder: Das Brot hat es bloß gegeben einmal am Tag.
Esther Krueger: . . . sie haben uns nicht mehr Brot gegeben. [unverständlich] Brot für den ganzen Tag. Und zwei mal am Tag...nein, zwei Mal in der Woche haben wir bekommen Marmelade zum Brot.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Einen Löffel Marmelade. Und so haben wir gelebt die ganze Zeit, die halben Juden in Werk B. Und nachher...
David Boder: In Werk was?
Esther Krueger: In Werk B. Skarzysko hat drei Werke gehabt, Werk A, Werk B und Werk C.
David Boder: Hm. Und Sie haben gelebt in Werk B.
Esther Krueger: Werk B.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Das ärgste Werk ist gewesen Werk C. Das Pikrina da war, war es „gelbe“ Arbeit. Bei der Arbeit sind viel gestorben.
David Boder: Was für eine Arbeit?
Esther Krueger: Pikrina, das ist „gelbe“ Arbeit.
David Boder: Was heiß das?
Esther Krueger: Das ist so ein gelbes...von was man macht Munition.
David Boder: Hülsen.
Esther Krueger: Gelbe Arbeit—Hülsen. Man wird sofort gelb von der Arbeit.
David Boder: Oh, man wird gelb...
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: . . . von der Arbeit. Was für eine Arbeit ist es, dass man wird gelb?
Esther Krueger: Ich habe dort nicht gearbeitet. Ich war ja im zweiten Werk.
David Boder: OK.
Esther Krueger: Aber ich habe gesehen die Menschen was sind gelb.
David Boder: Aha—und nun?
Esther Krueger: Und unser Werk ist nicht gewesen das Ärgste, aber die deutschen Meister sind gewesen die Ärgsten in unserem Werk. Da ist gewesen ein Meister Herring. Der hat viele Tage geschlagen die Juden und viele Juden hat totgeschlagen. Jede zwei...
David Boder: Hat er die wirklich tot geschlagen?
Esther Krueger: Zu Tode geschlagen. Wenn ein Jude hat etwas nicht gemacht in Ordnung bei der Maschine, da war es Sabotage, da hat es geheißen Sabotage.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Er hat es mit bösem Willen gemacht. Er hat ihm dazu so [unverständlich] in den Magen herein, er hat ihm einen Fußtritt gegeben, dass...
David Boder: Ein Moment, womit hat er das getan?
Esther Krueger: Wie bitte?
David Boder: Womit hat er das getan?
Esther Krueger: Mit dem Fuß, mit dem Stiefel.
David Boder: Mit dem Fuß.
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: Mit den Stiefeln.
Esther Krueger: Da hat er ihn so stark gestoßen, dass die Eingeweide runter gefallen sind und die Person am Boden gefallen ist. Er hat vielleicht noch zwei, drei Tage gelebt...
David Boder: Und...
Esther Krueger: . . . und dann ist er gestorben.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Und bei diesen Sachen auch, also es ist jede zweite Woche gewesen...hm, im Polnischen...wie heißt das...
David Boder: Sagen Sie es auf polnisch.
Esther Krueger: Hm,...Przebiurki.
David Boder: Ja. Selektion.
Esther Krueger: Jede zwei Wochen hat man selektiert die Menschen.
David Boder: Hm. Selektion.
Esther Krueger: Es war Selektion jede zwei Wochen. Man hat die Menschen in den Wald und da aus geschossen.
David Boder: Gleich dort?
Esther Krueger: Ja. Gleich bei Werk B im Wald.
David Boder: Wer hat das gesehen?
Esther Krueger: Das haben viele Juden gesehen. Wenn es sind vorbei zwei (2) Wochen, hat er gesagt, diese und diese, weil sie hat vielleicht schlecht ausgesehen...
David Boder: Aha.
Esther Krueger: . . . oder die war nicht so hübsch angezogen. Man hat aufgeschrieben die Nummer, weil jeder hat gehabt eine Nummer
David Boder: Ja?
Esther Krueger: . . . und den Namen aufgeschrieben. Und sie haben alle gewusst, dass man sie in den Wald führt in den Tod. Wenn einige Tage [unverständlich] .. dann ist gekommen die jüdische Polizei und hat gesagt: „Diese Namen, diese Namen“. Dann haben sie sich verabschiedet von den restlichen Juden und man hat sie geführt in den Wald.
David Boder: Und was hat die jüdische Polizei dort getan?
Esther Krueger: Es war nur die jüdische Polizei, die die Juden zur Arbeit gebracht haben, zur Fabrik...
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: . . . und am Abend zurück bringen...
Esther Krueger: . . . das keine Juden fort gehen von dem Lager.
David Boder: Ja, nun, was die jüdische Polizei gehabt zu tun mit dem Erschießen?
Esther Krueger: Die jüdische Polizei haben nicht geschossen. Sie haben nur die Juden zugeführt und übergeben an die Ukrainer...
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: . . . und dann geführt in den Wald und nachher...
David Boder: Die jüdische Polizei hat das tun müssen?
Esther Krueger: Ja. Und nachher haben die Ukrainer übernommen die Juden und haben sie aus geschossen.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Wir haben gehört die Schüsse und nachher...
David Boder: Sie haben gehört...? (beide sprechen)
Esther Krueger: Wir haben gehört in der Baracke, das ist nicht weit von der Baracke, von unserer Baracke. Und nachher sind sie nicht mehr zurück gekommen.
David Boder: Und was heißt hübsch—hübsch angezogen? Hat man gehabt seine eigenen Kleider, die man konnte anziehen?
Esther Krueger: Also wir mussten sehen, dass die Kleider, die wir haben gehabt, seien nicht zerrissen und nicht schmutzig und...
David Boder: Ah hm.
Esther Krueger: . . . und Etliche, die haben Hunger, konnten sich nicht halten so...
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: . . . rein.
Esther Krueger: Da haben sie sich unrein verhalten, weil sie haben sehr gehungert. Und ich...ich war das gewohnt, ich habe gewusst was rein halten heißt [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Ein Moment.
Esther Krueger: . . . aber nicht alle haben gekonnt sich so halten.
David Boder: [In English] Esther is a chubby, good looking, now plump and young girl of twenty (20). She is not understanding what I am saying and I caught her ... I got her in interrupting her ways about washing and she has put down here on the table a piece of soap. She was going to do either some washing, hm, to groom herself or, hm, to wash some ..... to do some laundry. She is very well groomed. There is no Rouge or anything, but she has a very healthy and pleasant look.
David Boder: [In German] Also weiter. Haben Sie verstanden was ich hab gesagt? Nein (lacht etwas) na, gut. (lacht wieder)
David Boder: [In English] Her teeth are exceptionally good.
David Boder: [In German] Sie haben sehr schöne Zähne.
Esther Krueger: Sie sprechen im Englischen?
David Boder: Ja, Englisch hab ich gesagt. Nun weiter.
Esther Krueger: Sie wurden erschossen.
David Boder: Also sie wurden erschossen.
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: Die Mädchen.
Esther Krueger: Also es hat passiert auch viele Male, ein Mädchen hat gekocht Suppe für sich. Sie hat bekommen etwas Kartoffel. So hat sie genommen von der [unverständlich]...Flocken, davon hat man gemacht Suppe.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: So hat sie genommen die paar Kartoffel und hat Supp gekocht. Sie hat gar nichts gewusst. Ihr Name war geschrieben, aber sie weiß nicht, wann sie gerufen worden.
Esther Krueger: Und mitten beim Kochen...
David Boder: Wo hat sie gekocht? Hm, hm, wo hat sie die Suppe gekocht?
Esther Krueger: Ja, bei uns in der Baracke ist gewesen im Winter...da haben wir gehabt so kleine Öfen zum Heizen...
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: . . . deshalb ist es dann nicht so kalt.
David Boder: Hm. Nun weiter.
Esther Krueger: So haben wir gekocht. Hat sie gekocht ein bisschen Supp und sie hat gar nichts gewusst. In dem Moment kommt herein ein jüdischer Polizei und sagt ihren Namen. Sie hatte gemusst lassen die Supp, ja, sie hat gewusst, dass sie sie nicht mehr essen wird. Sie ist schon nicht mehr hier. Sie hat verabschiedet und hat sie müssen alles verlassen. Sie hat genau gewusst, dass sie geht zum Tode, aber sie hat keinen anderen Ausweg gehabt.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Es ist auch manchmal passiert, dass sich die jüdischen Buben haben sich geschlagen mit der Polizei. Wenn man hat gewollt sie nehmen in den Wald, dann haben sie...
David Boder: Die jüdische Polizei?
Esther Krueger: Mit der jüdischen Polizei. Sie haben nicht gewollt gehen. Aber die jüdische Polizei haben gar nicht gekönnt helfen. Wenn der SS Mann hat gesagt „Ihr habt diese und diese zu bringen - diese Leute“ haben sie müssen die sofort bringen. Und diese gewusst sowieso sie gehen auf den Tod und haben nicht gewollt gehen. Und sie haben etliche Male geschlagen die Polizisten.
David Boder: Also die jüdische Polizei haben gehabt Revolver, Gewehre, Büchsen?
Esther Krueger: Ne, nein, die haben gar keine Waffen gehabt. Nur einen , so ein Stück...so...
David Boder: Stock.
Esther Krueger: Einen Stock, mehr nicht.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Und so ist es gewesen, so haben wir gelebt, das war alles. Wir haben nicht gewisst, wie lange wir werden leben. Und wir haben gewusst, es wird kommen die Zeit, wenn wir auch ausgesucht werden und [unverständlich] zum Tod. Aber ich habe mir .. es hat mir gar nichts gemacht. Ich habe schon gewusst, keine Eltern hab ich nicht, kein Schwester und Bruder auch nicht. Von der Familie ist keiner nicht geblieben, nur ich alleine. Es hat mir gar nichts gemacht., wenn zu Tode, dann zu Tod. Aber heute leb ich und was morgen wird sein, hab ich gar nicht gewusst. Nachher ist geführt Werk B auf Werk A, auch in Skarzysko. Und ich bin geblieben auf Werk A. Werk A war viel besser, weil wir konnten...wir haben uns gelernt stricken.
Esther Krueger: Handarbeit. Strümpf und Handschuh.
David Boder: Handschuh?
Esther Krueger: Handschuh, ja. Hab ich doch verdient und habe es gegeben für zu kaufen ein Stückchen Brot und machen ein Kleid oder [unverständlich] und Seife hab ich können kaufen. Ich hab schon nicht mehr verkaufen die Portion vom Brot. Und...
David Boder: Und Sie haben gelernt zu stricken in der freien Zeit, nicht, ind er Fabrik haben Sie doch nicht gestrickt?
Esther Krueger: Ich habe gelernt Stricken in der Baracke.
David Boder: Aha.
Esther Krueger: Wenn ich bin gekommen um sieben (7) Uhr von der Arbeit, habe ich gelernt Stricken bis neun (9) Uhr. Zwei (2) Stunden.
David Boder: Haben die Deutschen erlaubt herein zu bringen Wolle oder solche Sachen?
Esther Krueger: Das haben die Deutschen nicht gewusst.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Die Deutschen haben uns nur [unverständlich] bei der Arbeit, aber wenn wir sind gekommen zu Hause, dann sind wir nur gewesen bewacht von...und haben seit dem ersten (1.) Tag bewacht von der jüdischen Polizei.
David Boder: Männer oder Frauen?
Esther Krueger: Männer, nur Männer.
David Boder: Ja. Und nachher?
Esther Krueger: Und nachher habe ich gelernt stricken. Ich habe das mit meine...mit meiner Kameradin...mit dem Mädel...auch gut verdient. Und so habe ich gelebt die ganze Zeit. Ich bin auch gewesen in dem Werk...
David Boder: Haben sie gezahlt für die Arbeit?
Esther Krueger: Ja, für die Arbeit haben wir bekommen von andere wieder bekommen Brot oder wir haben bekommen Geld, polnisches Geld.
David Boder: Nein, nein, ich meine für die Arbeit in der Fabrik, hat man bezahlt?
Esther Krueger: Nein...für die Arbeit in der Fabrik haben wir gar nichts bekommen. Wir haben nur gebetet für Eines, wir sollen bleiben am Leben von der Arbeit.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Sonst gar nichts.
David Boder: Also, Ihr habt gelernt Stricken.
Esther Krueger: Und nachher haben wir gelernt Stricken. Wenn ich schon gekonnt habe Stricken, habe ich doch verdient. Habe ich Geld gehabt auf Seife, Kleidung da zu machen und ein Stückchen Brot hab ich können dazu kaufen.
David Boder: Nun?
Esther Krueger: Und nachher...
David Boder: Wo hast Du gekauft das Brot?
Esther Krueger: Das Brot haben gebringt...die Polnischen haben gebringt für sich. Sie haben es gebracht für sich, dass die Deutschen es nicht wissen und sie haben es verkauft für viel mehr Geld als es hat gekostet in der Stadt.
David Boder: Mit was hast Du gezahlt. Mit Geld oder Waren?
Esther Krueger: Wir haben gezahlt mit Geld und Sachen. Wer hat Geld, der hat Geld gegeben und wer gehabt hat Sachen von zu Hause, hat gezahlt mit Sachen.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Ich habe auch gehabt Sachen von zu Hause. Dann bin ich krank geworden—Flecktyphus.
David Boder: Flecktyphus?
Esther Krueger: Flecktyphus.
David Boder: Haben Sie gehabt Läuse?
Esther Krueger: Nein. Das ist gewesen so, wenn Einer hat das gehabt und hat von Hunger bekommen oder so vom Schmutz und der Zweite. Meine Kameradin ist rein gekommen mit Flecktyphus und nachher habe ich das bekommen. Ich habe der Kameradin sehr geholfen, ich habe sie geführt zum Bad und ich habe sie gekämmt. Ich habe das alles übernommen von ihr.
David Boder: Hart sie gehabt Läuse?
Esther Krueger: Nun ja, wenn sie hat Fieber bekommen und Flecktyphus war sie im Spital. Und ich habe müssen gehen zur Arbeit. Ich habe gar keine Zeit, den ganzen Tag bei ihr zu sein, denn ich habe müssen sein bei der Arbeit. Und sie selbst hat nicht gekonnt waschen, ich hab sie gemusst waschen.
David Boder: Im Hospital?
Esther Krueger: Im Hospital. Erst ist sie gelegen in der Baracke, nachher im Hospital.
David Boder: Und wo haben Sie sie gewaschen? Wenn sie war im Spital oder wenn sie...
Esther Krueger: Wenn sie liegt in der Baracke habe ich sie gewaschen. Und nachher hat man sie genommen ins Hospital auf dem zweiten (2.) Werk.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Da habe ich nicht können sie waschen. Ich bin gekommen...zu ihr ins Spital auch ich war krank und habe bekommen Fieber vierzig (40). Da bin ich gekommen zu ihr ins Spital, sie hat mich nicht gekennt. Sie hat so ein hohes Fieber und sie hat mich nur ab und zu, sie hat mich...sie gar nichts gewusst. Und wenn sie mich hat erkannt, dann hat sie gemeint, ich bin zu ihr gekommen zum Waschen. Hat sie mir gesagt...laut: „Esther, wasch mich.“ Aber ich bin gefallen aus das Bett von großem Fieber.
David Boder: Habt ihr geschlafen mit dem Mädchen in der Baracke oder habt ihr gehabt separate Betten?
Esther Krueger: Ne, in der Baracke sind wir geschlafen alle zusammen, zwei Mann, ich bin geschlafen mit ihr.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Und...
David Boder: Wie war das—in einem Bett?
Esther Krueger: In einem Bett, solche Pritschenbetten.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Einstöckige Pritschen und zweistöckige Pritschen.
Esther Krueger: Und in einem Bett haben geschlafen zwei (2) Mann.
David Boder: Ja, zwei Frauen?
Esther Krueger: Ja. Und in dem Spital haben auf einer Pritsche geschlafen zehn (10) Mann auf...
David Boder: Auf einem Bett.
Esther Krueger: Auf einer Pritsche zehn (10.) Mann.
David Boder: Wie breit...wir gross war die Pritsche denn gewesen?
Esther Krueger: Die Pritsche hat gehabt zehn (10) Meter.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Das Schlafen war verschieden. Ich habe im Spital gehabt ein eigenes Bett, weil wenn meine Kameradin ist gekommen ein Bett, da hat nur sie geschlafen. Und wenn sie gesund geworden ist, das Bett bekam ich und ich habe in dem Bett geschlafen.
David Boder: Sind sie sonst gelegen im Spital zwei in einem Bett?
Esther Krueger: Ja, im Hospital sind sie legen zu fünf, zu sechs, zu zehn im Bett.
David Boder: Nun und wer seien gewesen die Doktoren?
Esther Krueger: Es sind gewesen jüdische Sanitäter auch und Doktors, zwei oder drei Doktoren, auch Jüdische. Und alle paar Tage ist gewesen Kontrolle auch von Deutschen. Sie haben Viele gegeben zum Tod.
David Boder: Was soll das heißen?
Esther Krueger: Wenn ein Kranker ist gelegen fünf (5) Tage oder sechs (6), da haben die Deutschen gesagt, er kann schon nicht mehr gesund werden. Den Namen aufgeschrieben und nachher kommt Auto und er ist geführt auf den Wald und ist nicht mehr zurück gekommen.
David Boder: Und so, wie hatten sie...wie hat man sie ermordet? Hat man sie erschossen oder was?
Esther Krueger: Das weiß ich nicht, weil ich war in Werk A und ich weiß, man hat sie genommen nach Werk C.
David Boder: Was heißt man hat sie genommen nach Werk C?
Esther Krueger: Das ist ein zweites Werk in Skarzysko.
David Boder: Ja, aber Du bist gewesen im Hospital—im Revier. Und die Leute was sind genommen...
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: . . . die genommen wurden von dem Spital?
Esther Krueger: Die wurden genommen lebendig und...
David Boder: Und sie wurden gebracht wohin?
Esther Krueger: Sie wurden gebracht zu Werk C.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Und dann sind sie nicht mehr gekommen zurück.
David Boder: Also weißt Du nicht, ob man hat ihnen gegeben Injektionen oder was weißt Du?
Esther Krueger: Das weiß ich aber gar nicht.
David Boder: Und...
Esther Krueger: Das habe ich nicht gesehen.
David Boder: Nun?
Esther Krueger: Und nachher bin ich auch gesund geworden vom Typhus.
David Boder: Wie lange bist Du gewesen im Hospital?
Esther Krueger: Ich in gewesen fast vierzehn (14) Tage, bis...
David Boder: Aber Du hast gesagt, man kann nicht mehr wie fünf (5) Tage.
Esther Krueger: Nun ja, ich konnte den Deutschen nicht sagen, ich bin hier so lang. Wenn die sind gekommen, ich habe nicht so schlimm ausgesehen und ich habe gesagt, ich bin hier drei Tag.
David Boder: Und die Sanitärin hat nichts gesagt?
Esther Krueger: Nein, die jüdische Sanitärin hat gesagt, darf nicht mehr sagen als zwei, drei Tage.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Aber wer schon hat sehr schlimm ausgesehen, der hat nicht können sagen, weil die haben gesehen heute: ‚Bist Du schon länger hier als drei (3), vier (4) Tage’.
David Boder: Sind nicht gekommen die Selben, hat man Euch nicht erkannt?
Esther Krueger: Nein, die haben nicht gekannt, weil so Viele waren so krank, es waren etliche hundert Kranke, sie konnten sich nicht merken.
David Boder: [In English] We can see here, that I am trying to give them some searching questions, when it appears the horrible story does not make any sense.
David Boder: [In German] Nun weiter. So bist Du gesund geworden in vierzehn (14) Tag?
Esther Krueger: Ja, die [unverständlich] war vorbei und ich war wieder gesund. Und ich habe auch verkauft meine Kleider, die ich gehabt hab von daheim...für Kasche, um zu kochen etwas nach der Krankheit. Ich war sehr schwach, aber ich habe selbst gekocht.
David Boder: Nun?
Esther Krueger: Und nachher, ich bin gesund geworden. Ich bin sofort zu der Arbeit zurück gekommen. Ich bin gewesen auf Werk A ein Jahr und auf Werk B ein ein halb ( 1 ½ )Jahr. Nachher ist das ganze Lager Skarzysko nach Czenstokhov.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Wir haben gehört, dass die Russen kommen, da haben die Deutschen uns genommen und transferiert die ganze Fabrik nach Ska...nach Czenstokhov.
David Boder: Ja?
Esther Krueger: Czenstokhov...
David Boder: Wie hat man sie transferiert?
Esther Krueger: Von Skarzysko nach Czenstokhov.
David Boder: Nein, ich meine...
Esther Krueger: Mit der Bahn.
David Boder: Mit der Bahn?
Esther Krueger: Ja, mit den Wagons.
David Boder: Wie viele hat man rein gesteckt ins die Wagons?
Esther Krueger: In einen Wagon hat man herein genommen hundert (100) Mann, achtzig (80)...
David Boder: Mädchen meinen Sie?
Esther Krueger: Ja, hundert (100) Mädel und man hat gesehen Männer in der Bahn, weil es ist gewesen ein Lager für Mädel und für...
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: . . . Männer.
Esther Krueger: Zusammen. Wir sind dann gefahren und man hat gegeben auf den Weg ein kleines Stückchen Brot. Wir haben gehabt Hunger auf dem Weg.
David Boder: Wie lange sind Sie gefahren?
Esther Krueger: Wir sind nur gefahren einen Tag.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Einen Tag und eine halbe Nacht.
David Boder: Hat man Euch heraus gelassen zu gehen zum Kabinett oder [unverständlich]?
Esther Krueger: Nein.
David Boder: Wenn Leute mussten gehen?
Esther Krueger: Nein, gar nicht. Alle blieben in den Wagons vermacht.
David Boder: Und was hat man getan wenn man hat müssen raus gehen?
Esther Krueger: Oh, das war ganz verschieden. Man hat Töpfe noch gehabt vom...vom Lager und die haben sie genommen auf den Weg. [unverständlich]
David Boder: Hm, da waren da keine...
Esther Krueger: Nur Frauen.
David Boder: . Nur Frauen.
Esther Krueger: Ja. Man hat sich Einer vor dem Anderen nicht geniert, denn es geht nicht anders. Dann sind wir gekommen nach Czenstokhov. Von Czenstokhov hat man uns geführt auf Warta. Auch in Czenstokhov drei (3) Werke: Czenstokhovianka, Warta and Pelcery. In bin geblieben in dem Werk Warta. Das ist das Werk an dem Wasser Warta..
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Wir haben auch gearbeitet bei den selben Maschinen wie in Skarzysko. Es ist gewesen schon sehr viel besser. Wir haben bekommen ein halbes Kilo Brot für einen Mann, jeden Tag am Abend haben wir bekommen und bessere Suppe, eine Dickere und viel mehr als in Skarzysko. Es war das Leben schon viel besser.
David Boder: Und er hat Euch bewacht?
Esther Krueger: Uns hat bewacht...die Deutschen haben uns [unverständlich] von alle Seiten.
David Boder: Waren sie von der SS oder der Wehrmacht?
Esther Krueger: Nein, Wehrmacht und Ukrainer, Werkschutz.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Und wir...das Leben war viel besser als in Skarzysko. Wir haben gewusst, die Front kommt schon näher und näher und vielleicht werden wir befreit. Aber wir haben nicht...
David Boder: Haben die Euch geschlagen?
Esther Krueger: Nein, das ist nicht gewesen dort. Wir haben nicht so viel bekommen wie in Skarzysko. Es waren viel bessere Deutsche als in Skarzysko.
David Boder: In welchem Jahr ist das gewesen?
Esther Krueger: Das ist gewesen im fünf und vierzigsten (45) Jahr.
David Boder: Im Jahre fünf und vierzig (45).
Esther Krueger: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Von vier und vierzig (44) bis fünf und vierzig (45). Es war schon gegen Ende fünf und vierzig (45), weil wir wurden befreit im Jahr fünf und vierzig (45). Und wir haben so gelebt in Czenstokhov und das Leben war nicht so schlimm wie in Skarzysko. Wir haben bekommen viel mehr zu essen Suppe, ein halbes Kilo Brot und so haben wir gelebt. Und nachher haben wir auch gewusst die Front kommt näher und wir werden befreit. Dabei haben wir nicht geglaubt, dass es wahr ist...
David Boder: Nun?
Esther Krueger: Wir haben nicht geglaubt, dass wir das überleben, weil alle haben gesagt zu alle Juden: ‚Wenn die Freiheit wird kommen um zwölf (12)...um zwölf (12) Uhr, dann um halb zwölf machen die alle Juden tot die Deutschen.“
David Boder: Ein Ende.
Esther Krueger: Ja, ein Ende. Dann haben wir nicht geglaubt, dass wir überleben diesen Krieg. Aber ganz unerwartet am Montag ist es gewesen, da haben die Deutschen alle Juden, alle Männer raus geführt nach Deutschland. Es ist gewesen am fünfzehnten Ersten.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Und am Dienstag, am zweiten Tag, haben sie gewollt weg führen alle Frauen. Es war in der Nacht und die Scharen sind da gestanden, es war ein großer Frost und sehr kalt und es gibt ein Wunder—eines—es sind nicht gewesen Wagons da, die uns weg transportieren konnten und wir sind geblieben in Czenstokhov. Nachher, das war um fünf (5) Uhr am Abend hat das Bombardement angefangen. Wir wurden bombardiert. Die Russen haben bombardiert ganz Czenstokhov und bei Nacht sind sie gekommen nach Czenstokhov, die Russen. Die Deutschen haben verlassen das Lager. Da haben sich gefreut schon die Juden, wenn die Russen sind angekommen. Ich selbst habe nicht gewollt glauben, ich habe es gesehen, wie die Juden haben die Büchsen genommen, aber ich habe das alles nicht gewollt glauben, dass es möglich ist und dass es wahr ist, dass wir diesen Krieg überlebt haben, diesen gefährlichen Krieg. Aber es ist gewesen alles wahr. Am Morgen haben wir das Lager verlassen und wir sind in Czenstokhov auf der Gasse und wir haben getroffen viele Deutsches Militär, alles tot...und wir haben gesehen die Freiheit. Russen sind gekommen. Wir haben auch viel jüdische...viele jüdische Russen gesehen, die in dem russischen Militär sind. Die haben uns gesagt, dass die Freiheit ist gekommen zu uns. Wir haben das alles überlebt, das ist wahr und wir sollen fahren nach Hause und suchen unsere [unverständlich], unsere Familie. Mir tut es sehr leid, ich habe gewusst, ich habe keinen von der Familie, aber ich habe gedacht, vielleicht, Esther, vielleicht ist doch jemand geblieben von meiner Familie. Ich bin gefahren in drei Tagen bin ich nach Hause gekommen. Unser Haus ist...da hat gewohnt eine polnische Frau. Die hat mir gesagt von meiner Familie ist keiner, kein Einer nicht geblieben. Ich bin geblieben wohnen bei der Christin. Ich habe dort gewohnt .. habe ich gewohnt etliche Monate. Und nachher habe ich gewusst, dass das existiert ein Kibbuzim für Juden.
David Boder: Das haben Sie vorher nicht gewusst?
Esther Krueger: Ich habe gar nichts gewusst, dass es das gibt. Ich habe nicht gewusst was zu tun. Zu bleiben bei dieser Polnischen oder weg zu fahren. Ich habe gar nichts gewusst. Aber nachher bin ich gefahren zum Kibbuz. Dort hab ich getroffen viele Juden, viele jüdische Mädchen.
David Boder: Wohin sind Sie gefahren in den Kibbuz?
Esther Krueger: Ich bin gefahren nach Sosnowie.
David Boder: Oh, Sosnowie.
Esther Krueger: Ja. In Sosnowie bin ich geblieben im Kibbuz, mit allen...viel Mädeln sind gewesen und Kinder. Wir haben dort [unverständlich]. So wie ein Kibbuz da gewesen ist, war viel besser. Essen ist gewesen genug. Und bald haben wir selber alles gemacht.
David Boder: Wer hat das Essen gegeben?
Esther Krueger: Das Essen war...das war ein [unverständlich], der bringt Geld und wir haben selbst gekocht und alles selbst gekauft.
David Boder: Und von wo hat er das Geld bekommen?
Esther Krueger: Das wüsst ich nicht.
David Boder: Sie wissen es nicht.
Esther Krueger: Er hat nur gebringt das Geld.
David Boder: Ja, nun und dann?
Esther Krueger: Und von USA kam Geld von Joint. Und wir haben—davon haben wir gekauft und haben gelebt. Wir haben gelebt, wir haben bekommen Essen und unsere Kleidung. Wir sind gewesen in Sosnowie etliche Monate, dann sind wir gefahren. Wir haben gewollt fahren nach Italien, aber wir haben nicht gekonnt fahren nach Italien.
David Boder: Ja?
Esther Krueger: Ist gewesen zu gemacht die Grenze. So sind wir geblieben in Österreich. In Österreich ist es gewesen sehr schlecht, wir haben kein Essen nicht gehabt. Wir haben sehr wenig bekommen.
David Boder: Wer war in Österreich, die Engländer oder die Ameri...(beide sprechen)
Esther Krueger: Die Engländer.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Wir haben kein Essen nicht gehabt, wir haben sehr wenig bekommen. Genau so viel wie im Lager in Hitlers Zeiten.
David Boder: Also wenig gewesen?
Esther Krueger: Sehr wenig. Wenig Brot und wenig Supp. Nachher sind wir gefahren von Österreich nach Deutschland.
David Boder: Hat man Euch rüber gelassen über die Grenz oder seid Ihr so gegangen?
Esther Krueger: Wir sind gegangen über die Grenze, alle Grenzen haben wir...
David Boder: Wie viele Leute alle zusammen?
Esther Krueger: Es war verschieden. Einmal ist gegangen...
David Boder: Sie mit Eurer Gruppe.
Esther Krueger: Wir waren hundert und zwanzig (120). Wir sind gegangen über die Berge zu Fuß.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Russisches Militär hat uns gefangen. Wir sind zurück gegangen, dann noch einmal über die Berge und dann sind wir durch gekommen.
David Boder: Nach wo? Nach Deutschland?
Esther Krueger: Nach Deutschland.
David Boder: Und von Deutschland seid Ihr gegangen?
Esther Krueger: Deutschland—wir sind geblieben etliche Wochen und nachher sind wir gefahren nach Italien. Und jetzt sind wir in Italien.
David Boder: Und Ihr wartet jetzt. Wie heißt der Kibbuz?
Esther Krueger: Unser Kibbuz heißt Nocham.
David Boder: Kibbuz Nocham.
Esther Krueger: Nocham. Noah-Chalutzim Meichad.
David Boder: Schreib, hm, schreib es auf. Noah?
Esther Krueger: Noah-Chalutzim Meichad
David Boder: Hm. Und was heißt das auf deutsch, jiddisch?
Esther Krueger: Das ist, hm,...eine Sammlung von jungen Chalutzim.
David Boder: Ja und jetzt wartest Du zu gehen...
Esther Krueger: Jetzt sind wir hier und warten eine weitere Zeit.
David Boder: Und was machen die Leut hier den ganzen Tag?
Esther Krueger: Den ganzen Tag...das ist verschieden auch. Ein Appell ist da...und ich stricke auch, ich mach Strümpf.
David Boder: Hm.
Esther Krueger: Heute auch.
Esther Krueger: Ist verschieden. Wer hat eine Arbeit, das macht er. Er wascht und...
David Boder: Versteht Ihr hebräisch? Kannst Du hebräisch?
Esther Krueger: Ja, ich verstehe hebräisch, aber nicht so gut. Ich habe es gelernt nach dem Krieg, nicht lang. Ich kann lesen, aber ich verstehe es nicht so gut.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool hundred, hm,...this concludes, hm, ..... this concludes Spool one hundred and nine. Ester Krüger, hm, who belongs to a Kibbuz, who went through her, hm, her work in a slave labor situation. She has no tattoo. She was in reasonably clean conditions although she went through typhus. And now she is here in Tradate, Italy, expecting by ..... legally or by illegally to reach Palästina.
David Boder: [In German] Sind Sie verheirat?
Esther Krueger: Nein.
David Boder: Nein.
Esther Krueger: Das alles habe ich gegeben schon kurz!
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Krueger: Die ganzen Erlebnisse.
Esther Krueger: Also, wenn man das Buch zu schreiben hat, ist zu schreiben sehr viel mehr.
David Boder: Ja, natürlich. Ich wollte, es wäre nicht gewesen so kurz, hm, ein ganzes Buch dann machen über alle Erlebnisse, aber ich werd sehen, vielleicht kommen wir noch einmal zusammen...zum Schreiben.
Esther Krueger: In der Zukunft alles beschreiben.